welcome to the Center for strategic and
International Studies we're here for a
conversation with the director general
of the international atomic energy
agency Rafael Grossi who was just
reappointed by by the iaea Board of
Governors for another four-year term as
director General congratulations
congratulations also for a somewhat
recent World Cup victory for Argentina
uh
director General Grossi oversees the
iaea at a critical period in the
organization's history obviously we've
got major war taking place around
nuclear power plants in around Ukraine
director General groceries here today to
describe the efforts to safeguard these
critical facilities from that ongoing
war in Ukraine the protection of power
plants in Ukraine is not the sole issue
concerning the iaea at the moment the
director General recently traveled to
Iran and is overseeing the agency's
verification and monitoring
responsibilities related to The Joint
comprehensive plan of action and the
ongoing concerns about Iran's nuclear
program
the agency is also continuing to work
closely with August Partners to develop
detailed verification arrangements for
Australia's acquisition of
nuclear-powered submarines so just to be
clear ongoing war in Ukraine Iran
nuclear weapons and August all in the
news uh on front on the front pages of
most newspapers this week so you're
operating in a very uh hot environment
these are just a few of the items on a
long lift list of efforts
and responsibilities managed by director
General Grossi in the iaea to safeguard
nuclear material around the world
director General Grossi is here at csis
joining us this afternoon after meeting
with our 2023 cohort of nuclear Scholars
it's a program run by the project on
nuclear issues here at csis for young
professionals to learn from and network
with nuclear experts from around the
world obviously including the director
of the iaea moderating this session will
be Dr Heather Williams director of the
csis project on nuclear issues and a
senior fellow with csis International
Security program so Heather I hand the
floor over to you thank you very much
for hosting this
thank you very much for the introduction
um hello everybody as Dr Jones said I'm
Heather Williams I'm the director of the
project on nuclear issues affectionately
known as Pony and we are just absolutely
thrilled today for today's discussion
with director general of the iea Raphael
Grossi for those of you in person also
for those of you joining virtually thank
you so much for joining this important
conversation as Dr Jones said there's a
lot of ground to cover here uh Ukraine
Iran August before we dive into all of
that uh just a couple quick housekeeping
items the first is I do need to share
with for those of you in the room our
buildings uh safety precautions overall
we feel secure in our building but as a
convener we have a duty to prepare for
any eventuality I will serve as a
responsible safety officer in that event
please follow my instructions should the
need arise and so finally please take a
moment to familiar familiarize yourself
with our emergency exit Pathways there
there there
um for the question and answer portion
so director General grossey will provide
some opening remarks and then we will
open it up for a wider discussion uh if
you are in the room and wish to get
involved please raise your hand and a
member of the pony staff will bring you
a microphone if you're joining us online
please send in questions using the
Google form that is located on the
webpage for this event so with that um
out of the way I am thrilled to get this
conversation started iea director
General Rafael Grossi assumed office on
December 3rd 2019 and was just
reappointed for his term DG Grossi is a
diplomat with more than 35 years of
experience in the fields of
non-proliferation and disarmament in
2013 he was appointed ambassador of
Argentina to Austria in the Argentine
representative to the iaea and other
vienna-based International organizations
before assuming office is the iea's
direct Dr General DG Grossi was
president designee of the 2020 review
conference for the nuclear
nonproliferation treaty which didn't end
up happening until 2022 I believe uh but
from 2014 to 2016 he also served as
president of the nuclear suppliers group
and so we're just thrilled to have
somebody of his expertise and background
at such a timely moment to join us and
talk about these issues and with that I
will turn it over to you and please feel
free to use the podium
uh good afternoon good afternoon
everybody Heather uh great to to be with
you again and to see you in your new
capacity uh congratulations
um and also those here in in the room
and and online
um in this uh troubled times is good to
be in centers of uh thought and Analysis
like the csis and pony in particular to
be able to explain what we are trying to
do about some of these problems and also
to get some of your feedback your
comments your questions that certainly
helped me be better in what I'm trying
to do I think that in your
words of introduction you were listing a
number of issues uh all of them making
the headlines every day
and and this
brings us to to the realization of the
the iea is an institution
as an institution as an international
organization
playing a role maybe not at the center
but playing a central role in all all of
them is the expression of the will of
the International Community
to find spaces for convergence when the
iea was was created
incidentally
and we are going to be celebrating that
in a few months time but after a seminal
statement each pronounced 70 years ago
in 1953 precisely and now we are
starting 2023
was on this concept
that saw the light here in America
of having this tremendous opportunity of
nuclear science and technology for peace
and for development then the Mission
evolved taking us to where we are today
where the institution is is able to
contribute to prevent
crisis and hopefully uh the worst
consequences of War
um and to prevent situations to uh get
worse like in the case of of Iran and in
other places where proliferation
questions are are being raised
so
not to mention I think here we we might
add
our role or the the role that we are
playing and can play in terms of the
energy crisis and the energy security
crisis which are two different things
and on both the iaea has an important
role to play and I always like to to
remember even if I'm in my I am in an
August circle of strategic thinkers that
the iaea does a lot of good to to
improve the lives of millions across the
planet providing
Cancer Care through nuclear medicine
through radiotherapy
giving countries hope in terms of their
agriculture water management and other
things don't forget that because those
elements are also also as strategic
thinkers because these elements are also
part of the behavioral response of
communities across the world to the iaea
and to what the iea means for them and
can do for them I would say this is
a moment where our generation is
confronted with this amazing convergence
of all these crisis and all of a sudden
we need wisdom to respond to them and we
need to have the tools to to address
them and the iea is one of them just one
of them
but I believe uh one that can do a lot
of good in in facing all these
situations so we are dealing with them
and I'm here in Washington at a very
particular moment where just 24 hours
ago the president of this country with
the prime minister or the prime minister
of two important Nations the United
Kingdom and Australia announced a very
ambitious project that for the first
time in history is going to allow a
country that does not have nuclear
weapons to be
equipped with nuclear-powered capacities
which will have an important strategic
effect and you know all of this and in
all of these again the iea is called to
play a role which is in itself
in an area that is by nature strategic
because this is going to be altering the
landscape of an important region like
the in the Pacific where many of the
controversies and tensions that we are
facing are going to be manifesting
themselves whether we like it or not in
the next few decades so in all of this
the iaea what the iaea is doing what the
iea can do is what I am going to try to
answer today
through the I'm sure
we're going to be your very sharp
questions so my pleasure to be with you
again and in your hands Heather to stop
art
looking at this thing through the unique
prism of your questions thank you very
much
[Applause]
well thank you very much for um setting
the scene and I'm continuing to engage
with these really difficult questions so
I have a couple questions for you to get
us started
um we'll start we'll start with Ukraine
yes
uh I believe it was last week you gave a
speech in which you warned that the
International Community was being
complacent about nuclear safety and that
we were rolling the dice and it was some
of the most emphatic and strongest
language that I've heard you use yet
about concerns about nuclear Safety and
Security and so I I was wondering if you
could reflect on that a bit and say what
why do you think we're complacent where
is that coming from and what needs to be
done to combat that complacency about
nuclear Safety and Security
well I believe that at certain moments
it is important
when confronted with such dramatic
circumstances
to face the the facts
to express them in all Clarity and not
to sugarcoat
what could be the consequences of Our
Own inaction
um in in the face or of these issues as
head of an international organization
I'm not one of those who say well I'm in
the hands of member states I can do only
what member states allow me to do this
is not the healthy Dynamic that you must
have in an international organization
when you have a responsibility on behalf
of these countries under their authority
of course but where you have to play
your role in the metabolism of that
dynamic
so I have a mission I have a statute I
have responsibilities and it is up to me
to tell
my member states member states
let's pause for a second
and let's do something about this of
course
this
thing to be done must be politically
possible viable
and my impression is that we have viable
Solutions on the table
and I've been working on on a proposal
to provide protection
to the plant for many months and I felt
last week the sixth
sixth time where the largest biggest
nuclear power plant in Europe was being
cooled through emergency emergency
diesel generators that we shouldn't be
in that position that it was not it is
not needed to be in that position
and that we as iea and member states of
the iea could
support
the efforts of the director General
to put us in a better position we are
not pretending to end the conflict here
we are not pretending to buy some magic
give the plant back to to its legitimate
owner which hopefully will happen in a
not too distant future but we have a
problem that we need to solve and there
is an immense risk and I would I
wouldn't be doing any service to my
office or to the International Community
if I was to Simply let it pass as
something that you know too bad is not
happening
um it is you know these member states
they are stubborn no it is my
responsibility to continue pushing to
put viable viable ideas on the table to
explain how this can work
and also to get the necessary support so
it was in this sense and it was I would
say a collective complacency I was not
I'm not above anybody I'm part of that
and I'm also telling to myself
how come
that you are not able to
convince that you are not able to make
things clear to make things possible for
countries to agree so it's a dynamic
it's a dynamic that must be leading to
an outcome and we are not there yet
hence my frustration but it is not a
frustration
that is
devoided of a sense of purpose and
fundamentally yes optimism I believe we
are going to be able to do something
about this
I I truly believe it
but there are moments and there are bad
moments and that was was a very dark one
and I hope we will not have a seventh
situation
or worse than that
an accident to to regret not having done
what we knew was necessary at the time
where we could still do it
you refer to this as Dynamic and I it
strikes me as a very challenging Dynamic
where on the one hand you recognize your
um your personal agency your personal
responsibility
um in the iaea's role in this while at
the same time as you said you you aren't
trying to get into solving this crisis
and and I'm curious if you could say a
bit about how you strike that political
balance given all of the diversity of
members
um
contributors to the iaea and that sense
of responsibility that you feel so
basically how do you walk the political
tightrope
well I think it is important to be aware
of uh
where countries are coming from
what their strategic objectives are
while not discussing them
or not having them on the table as part
of the negotiation but having
Clairvoyance in this regard
knowing what is behind countries
positions and objectives of course there
are limits to everything and when the
iaea and it has happened in the past
when the iaea
has needed to call out
Behavior
non-compliance with obligations it has
done so
the incredible situation now
is that we are doing it in in the midst
of a war
this has never happened before
but does this mean that we cannot do it
no it shouldn't sometimes when working
on issues
with my team and with other with experts
the argument is made it has never been
done before
well yes
have we ever seen a conflict like what
we are having in Ukraine before I don't
think so
do we believe that the instruments we
have are inadequate
to deal with that no
certainly certainly not
um so
walking this political tightrope is
inevitable
you also need
um engagement your personal engagement
you are there to assume the
responsibility which includes failing
maybe which includes paying the price of
your political your personal Capital
to be on the line
but this is what is essential it's a
clear and here you know thinkers like
you
help a lot
in our work we we read we study we
analyze we weigh what is at stake
but we know that we are not analysts
that's not our role in in the process
and we have to come with Alternatives
and solutions one of the things I always
try to do is never lose the initiative
and that in my professional life you
were saying that that that bio 35
unfortunately is close to 40 now years
of work in this is that when you know
what you need to do
you have to take the initiative you have
to be always putting forward
alternatives
nobody's going to do it for you there's
always going to be a good excuse not to
do something
so this is I believe in particular in a
moment like this where we have all this
multiplication of Crisis not to stay in
awe in front of all these things and on
the contrary
show that the iea is going to respond
the iaea is not going to stay away from
things the iaea is going to be deployed
all over Ukraine if the facilities in
Ukraine are a danger
and then the price tag for doing some
Foley is much higher
than it would be if the iaea would be or
the or its director General would be
tweeting from the Danube
on what is going on
thank you for that also thank you for it
sounds like an openness
um on your part and at the agency two
outside ideas into Solutions wherever
they come from it's always nice to hear
her as a think tanker that people read
Think Tank reports um so that that's
always that's helpful I want to shift to
August if we can yes a
um there was a story in Reuters in
September uh reporting that the iaea was
quote unquote satisfied with us UK and
Australian engagement in cooperation on
nuclear non-proliferation
at this stage would you say you are
satisfied with us UK and Australian
engagement and just really any
Reflections on the agency's role and
engagement with um us UK Australia in
the office agreement thus far well again
we are breaking you ground all of us
including the ocos countries and they
know it
they know it and for these I'm grateful
because they know they have an enormous
responsibility here because we all
sustain the non-proliferation regime and
we know that even if what is being
attempted by the office countries exists
and figures within the catalog
of available options
it is in the you have the possibility to
do this this has never done before again
going back to my previous comment
doesn't mean that it cannot be done
it can be done but it will require uh a
an enormous effort on everybody's side
because again we have to think of a
Level Playing Field we have to think of
observing the rules in a manner that is
applicable to all
and we have to think of a technological
option that
requires and this is the wisdom of the
legislator here requires some special
action because what is going to happen
is is relevant
a country is going to exclude
big amounts of nuclear material at very
high levels of enrichment from our
inspectors so Our obligation and their
commitment is there to to make it so
that we can account for the last gram
of that material
and we know it is technically possible
but that it will require
a big effort because there are
technological
issues you have to think that according
to what we learned yesterday the United
States will be selling incredibly
sensitive technology
around which there are many restrictions
confidentiality
classified information most of it if not
almost all is involved Australia is
going to receive it there are going to
be facilities
that are going to be hosting these boats
etc etc and we have to be able to
provide the technologically sound
answers to that if we don't do it
then there is a risk
there is a a big risk to the
nonproliferation regime so this is why
I've said
um in in the in these quotes that I I
was satisfied to see that these
countries were listening to us
that they understood
from the
from day one that what they were doing
was and I in the in the literacy sense
of the world of the world and not as an
adjective extraordinary
out of the ordinary which
demands out of the ordinary measures out
of the ordinary Behavior out of the
ordinary understandings
Among Us
so the bar is set as high as it possibly
can in terms of these people say
well if this happens other countries
will want that I don't know I don't know
that may or may not happen by the way
there is another country that has
already
invoked this possibility so it's not the
first
the the letter I got yesterday from Her
Excellency
Miss Penny Wong the the foreign minister
of Australia is not the first I receive
in this regard so the agency is already
embarked
to use a naval
analogy in in this thing it's going to
take an effort
I believe that if we put the best
of all of us
we can we can do it but of course we
will have to go through it I cannot and
and I think nobody would expect me to
say now
it's going to be fine
we have a lot of work to do
the conditions are there I see the
political commitment I see the
seriousness you heard President Biden
yesterday you heard prime minister
albanesi
with whom I have spoken about it
um we heard prime minister sunak as well
they are aware
and and their teams are are also ready
is a toll order we have to work there is
a lot of work ahead of us
thank you for that and just until you
said that you are satisfied that these
countries are listening that they
understand the seriousness and the
extraordinariness of it and
responsibility yes
um
so uh to follow up on that the iaea
statement on August mentioned foreign
minister Wong saying that they would be
requesting the agency to commence
negotiations on um article 14 of
Australia's um safeguards agreement I
was wondering if you have any sense what
is the timeline for this
well I I think the timeline will shall
have to adjust to the timely delivery of
the of the boats will have to be ahead
of a ahead of that well ahead of that so
this is why this is so complex
we will have to work in synchronicity
the legal the technical teams
with uh with the supplier
here in the United States and and with
Australia
and mind you the work has started we
already received preliminary design
information the the
uh the safeguards uh mechanisms and
commitments are are show that you have a
set of obligations that need to be
fulfilled
with as time passes so
the process has started and then we are
going to be starting this this
interaction safeguards negotiations are
very technical they are complex
um normally they they take some time
but here we have some time pressure of
course and we have to deliver in time
otherwise
let me remind you and I think the
countries are aware of this otherwise it
will not be possible for the agency to
say okay
so uh and and as I said in the statement
that was
issued uh today earlier earlier today
um the Board of Governors has to look at
it take appropriate action I think the
process is is uh is a model of
transparency the process we have to
fulfill it with content with real
content but the process is there
and there's everything we need
there in the catalog of measures now we
have to fill in the blanks
great thank you one last question for me
and then I'll be opening it up uh to the
audience so get your questions ready
this question uh so the key issues that
are on the agency's agenda at the moment
Ukraine Iran August these are obviously
taking place during a climate of great
power competition geopolitical
instability
um you're the head of a technical agency
how do you how how do you manage the
current political environment and as you
look ahead to your next four years as DG
what's concerning you the most right now
well
um
I think
um the technical nature of the of the
iea
um is is in its configuration it should
never be an excuse not to assume the
legal and political responsibilities
that come with it
the agency expresses itself in a domain
which is technical
but is based on a political and legal
commitment stemming from that 1953 idea
all right and which was
reflected uh in in in a body of law
so this is one one thing which is
important
the next few years will be years of a
mix of
reaction to crisis but also
also and very importantly enabling
possibilities for the international
committee and this is very very
important
when we deal with the energy security
crisis when we need with the
decarbonization of the energy mix in the
world when we deal with all these other
activities where nuclear Science and
Technology are real answers to needs
that we have as an International
Community I I take this as equally
important not less or more equally
important in this mix you and I have
worked on npt issues and we have
discussed and I think the audience is
aware of the this balance between
promotional developmental
um human development activities that are
intrinsically linked with nuclear
science and technology and the Strategic
side of the agenda so my impression my
aspiration is that we start
to move the needle
we start to move the needle in a
direction that will make a difference
when I see what happens in the world in
terms of access to radiotherapy I say to
myself that this is obscene
in terms of lack of access
and and we need to make a difference
we need to make a difference it's not
impossible at all and we need to take
this seriously
this is not the price for countries to
accept safeguards for God's sakes
this is part of the ethical moral
responsibility to deal with nuclear
science in a responsible way and the
iaea has not been able to be that
yet
so I think these four years ahead of us
are so exciting Heather
because if we get to realize the uh the
the the expressions of safeguards in
this way that we just described it in in
in Naval proportion that it's applicable
to ice breakers for example as well and
to other means of transportation and if
we do the other thing then it will be a
good four years
well I as you said you're an optimist so
I I'm fully confident you can achieve
all these things so we will check back
with you in four years and see how it's
looking uh so I'll open it up and we'll
take a couple of questions uh from the
room so we'll take gentlemen in the
front row here first if you could please
introduce yourself when you ask your
question
Capital intelligence CI Ukraine my
question goes to Mr uh Ambassador Grossi
uh we have a the nuclear plant which is
I believe six chernobyls
um what is the situation on the ground
today what needs to be done and what
else is the agency looking at protecting
other nuclear plants in Ukraine but also
possibly Russia in the Border I mean
this is the most serious nuclear threat
in our life Chernobyl and the plan and
the other plan no I mean that plan is
like six chernobyls I mean in size I
believe is the largest nuclear plant
nice bigger bigger so we have
potentially six Chernobyl accidents in
Europe I mean this is a lose-lose for
everyone so what's the position in the
uh on the ground on the Ukraine plant uh
says in B and what are you planning to
do for the to protect the other plants
in the in the area yes but thank you for
the question
of course the issue is is well we are
there
we have a isams which is our mission our
experts are there and have been there
already six rotations
um which is incommensurably important
because we not only uh are there
um to inform
which is Ina by itself a huge gain for
for all to be able to have impartial
eyes informing what what's happening or
what's not happening at the same time we
engage very actively with the operators
there we are involved in the in the uh
or are able to express our views on
decisions that have to do with the
operation of the plant we put questions
I mean we by by virtue of being there we
can weigh in a certain sense on what is
going going on there my goal is to uh
have a political commitment to protect
to avoid an accident that is my my most
important goal there although we are
going to stay performing all these other
functions the other facilities when the
um the the the the the war and the the
rates over vast areas of the Ukrainian
territory started over the past few
months I've been towards the end of the
summer and beginning of the Fall
president zelenski requested me to
deploy in all the other facilities which
we did I think here there's a
combination of a technical assistance
function and also the the very relevant
symbolic historic fact that the iaea
flag is flying atop these facilities of
a country at War thinking about things
that are happening now and we could
never imagine before and we have our
people there
and so the International Community knows
so we can be an alert on anything that
may be happening we do have also
technical missions technical activities
We performed a number of Assessments
before coming to them each facility T
has different issues safety wise and
security wise and we are working
together with Ukraine to solve them
through our the presence of our experts
there
thank you um another question from um in
the room I'm Ashley up here in front
please
hi thank you I'm wondering if you could
identify the key impediments standing in
the way of the iaea being able to
actually implement this Safety and
Security Zone in zapparesia well I think
it's it it it's no surprise that it's
it's difficult to get to any kind of
commitment when you have a
war and in particular in this area you
have active combat ongoing it's it's the
front line literally I I've been there
so
one side of the river it's the
ukrainians on the other side of the
river is the the Russians so it is war
in all its graphic
uh strength
that you can see it's palpable
so
when you put ideas on the table and
concrete proposals involving certain
commitments and behaviors it is obvious
that it's not going to be easy
uh this negotiating table is is a bigger
one now with military
when I go to Moscow or to kaliningrad or
to anywhere or when I when I'm in Kiev
with my Ukrainian natural interlocutors
I have military in front of me I have
diplomats as well and I have nuclear
people and I have legal experts but I
have
um unfortunately an ever-growing number
of people in green
in these negotiations so these
conversations which are of course
confidential by Nature have lots of
ingredients having to do with the
military activity ongoing there and how
different options and possibilities
would be affecting
these activities so this is why
it is not as straightforward as it could
be one could ask myself the question
whether it should be straightforward I
mean don't shoot at the nuclear power
plant but of course they are us there
are a number of associated
consequences that need to be weighed
um that being said
um I'm frustrated
but I don't dismay I continue I'm very
stubborn
from online we've we're getting quite a
few questions about Russia so I'm going
to group some of these together okay
um one of the questions is um about
whether or not the war in Ukraine has
impacted Russia's cooperation with the
iaea on issues Beyond zapparisha but
then also a question about what role of
any Russia and China have been playing
um in the jcpoa and if you believe that
they would assume a greater diplomatic
role if Iran does enrich up to 90 well
to start with the last part I would say
you know Russ China are part of the
jcpoa Partnership if I can call it like
that still
so and I think they have been with their
own
National nuances they have been playing
a role to try to revive the the jcpoa uh
so
um I I you know every country of core of
course sees things differently and and
quite obviously with growing tensions
and and unfortunately this uh cleavage
uh within jcpoa Partners uh among the
western side of the group and the and
Russia and China this of course has had
an impact in the dynamic of of that
process but
um I would say uh they have been working
like the others again with their own
particular approaches
towards the towards the the common goal
the other part is is a is a is an issue
that has been put on the table
many believe that given the war and
what's ongoing there should be uh
decreased presence of Russia and some
have gone to the extreme of proposing
that they are expelled from the
organization well these are
international organizations that have
procedures to do that
um I cannot decide myself to exclude a
country from uh from policy making
organs or uh from uh any other instance
in the organization of course this
creates tensions
this is unavoidable that tensions exist
we have to deal with them
I have to be prudent in my decisions I'm
sending people I'm sending teams of not
only to Ukraine
or to all over the planet I have teams
of inspectors so I have to exercise good
judgment
um
you know
a clear idea of what is best suited on
unsuitable to achieve the goals that
that we need and that we want to achieve
but let us be reminded of the fact that
in the 20th century we had many
instances of armed conflict involving
Nationals of countries involved in this
armed conflicts and and we need to
protect the idea the noble idea of the
international civil service
um can sound naive and people talk about
spies here there but it can be done it
must be done
and we have to uh again we have to
navigate these these Waters as as good
as we can always respecting our legal
framework which is at the end of the day
what will ensure that there is a
guarantee of fairness
thank you for that and I'm very quotable
protect the noble idea of the
international Civil Service I quite like
that one I'll take another question from
in the room
um in the back Russia please introduce
yourself
sure uh hello thank you first thank you
so much for just your commitment to the
non-proliferation regime it's truly
inspirational my name is Eunice I am a
PhD student at Johns Hopkins University
size and my question actually comes out
of what you were saying about how a lot
of what is going on is a reaction to the
midst of war and so I'm wondering
um what lessons you've personally taken
away from Ukraine from the Ukraine war
in terms of future Grand strategic
long-term planning for the iaea and
future crises and my second question
actually comes out of Heather's question
she asked you what you're most concerned
about but what makes you most hopeful so
that's something I'm curious about thank
you well
I'm learning every day
I'm learning every I'm seeing things
that I
could have never imagined
before I became a director General
they need to I will I would never
imagine that I would be dealing with
with uh my technical experts working in
occupied territory and doing that in
accordance to terms of reference being
agreed with the legitimate owner of the
plant who does not have any Authority on
the plant
while
juggling with a Workforce of ukrainians
under
Russian management
to cite just an easy example
of what we are dealing with here so
I'm sure that we are going to have lots
and we are already having lots of
lessons that we are learning that we are
incorporating into our own planning into
our own decision making
we now have uh I would say a very big
number of people working on specifically
on Ukraine in my department of nuclear
Safety and Security because you have to
think that behind these four or five
Brave women and men out there there is a
huge team
working at headquarters and in some
other places sustaining their effort
communicating with them helping them do
what they need to do so again for the
safety for the nuclear Safety and
Security Department this has also been a
a tremendously
disruptive in the literal sense of the
of the of the word phenomenon that have
led us to have to adapt and we used to
have we have a day job all right which
is the rest of the world
and we cannot when we have a problem
in another country we cannot say sorry
come later we are busy in Ukraine
so we we have to be everywhere
and we can
yes we can we can of course it takes
longer hours it takes more work but we
have to be an agency which is not only
there
for the easy times
especially we deliver a service and we
have to be there when when the going
gets rough and to provide some comfort
in the sense that you know that there
are people there and our Ukrainian
friends know that there are people there
watching trying to help trying to assist
and doing this kind of this kind of work
you know one one very moving thing that
we have with our missions is that the
people there the plant say don't leave
us
stay stay
so we need to have this in mind
all the time
so if that doesn't make you change the
work the way the way you work what can
but we need and we do it
um
that is uh to go from this affirmations
to to realities we are working on the
committee of safety standards we are
adapting we are twisting we are uh
fine-tuning uh all this uh all these
things
uh the other part of your question was
in in the face of those circumstances
well this is what make me optimism
is that we have an agency
that has reacted showed it could react
and not
um like uh when Chernobyl happened or
when Fukushima having go afterwards do
some report
about it yeah that's that's okay
we always need reports
uh you know the head of an insurance
organization has to say that we need
many reports yeah but we need to be
there when things are happening
and perhaps our reports will tell a
better story
thank you I think I'll take one or two
more
um uh right here please
thank you very much director General I'm
George sparram the Lincolnshire
Ambassador here in the United States my
question goes back to to your work in
subpoortia because I mean aside of many
things that this situation comes with
attacking a civilian nuclear power plant
is also a serious violation of
international humanitarian law and of
course we expect accountability as for
the many other violations that happen in
Ukraine do you see a role for the iaea
to contribute to judicial processes be
it by Ukraine or International
mechanisms to to provide accountability
and to in a way strengthen the legal
framework on which you rely again very
much yourself in the future thank you
well I would say
what we go and do something like this we
do it with a certain idea but according
to certain terms of reference
which by the way we agreed with Ukraine
because it's a Ukrainian facility
so we are centered on our nuclear Safety
and Security Mission this is what we
need to do and perhaps if I manage to
have something on the protection of the
plant we might be able to be reporting
more accurately on some aspects
more related to military activities at
the plant that being said it's not my in
my nature
to avoid problems when we can help
without mixing pears and apples
I will simply mention that when we could
work for example for example for the
release
of some Ukrainian
staff we did it and we managed to help
so but this is uh very delicate you may
understand and to be efficient we have
to be prudent
but we are never indifferent let me put
it like that
and I think we'll take another one
Michael here please
good afternoon sir Lieutenant Mike
Walker I'm a submarine officer in the
U.S Navy
um also a pony nuclear scholar
my question is about the acos agreement
so my understanding is that the first
phase of that agreement will involve the
transfer of the s9g power plant which
requires very high levels of enrichment
and then phase two will likely involve a
totally new plant design I'm curious if
you hold any views on that new plant
design like should we pursue lower
levels of enrichment in that plant
well the this
there are two phases like you're saying
and I think on on the second one there
are still many uh many issues that need
to be clarified and we understand from
uh from the August partners that a
number of uh technical details are still
being defined
we know that irrespective of the actual
technical
elements in the design
which are if you allow me less important
from for us than the actual
verifiability of the nuclear material
which is what counts for me irrespective
of the type of of the reactor the the
the technical configuration
what I can tell you is that the second
phase will be
very demanding because it will imply a
lot of activity in Australia
the Australians are going to start
building
constructing the submarines perhaps
they're going to get the the reactor but
still there is going to be a number of
facilities storage places Etc which are
going to demand specific inspection
activity
why because the proliferation points are
going to be much
higher I mean more
more numerous than what you would have
in a context of an acquisition of a
ready-made already constructed boat so I
see that the degree of of sophistication
of the approach is going to be
growing as we move into the into the
second phase but in any case we should
never forget about one thing at least
for us from from my perspective as the
from the iea our objective is to account
for the material
so we need to have the the tools the
Safeguard tools that would allow us
to do that and then to look at the
proliferation potential uh talk points
or or exit points to be able to secure
those
so last question is going to be a
gentleman in the middle here um and then
we'll wrap up we only have a couple
minutes left but I want to squeeze in
one more huh thank you very much thank
you very much just for your remarks and
comment about user proton understand the
nuclear the nuclear related issues my
question is about North Korea I think
that the North Korean nuclear program is
a vulnerable a major nuclear issues such
as the Ukraine role occurs and Iran you
mentioned uh within this context what is
your specific do you have any specific
plan on new or North Korea's nuclear
issue or how will the iaea deal with the
North Korea's nuclear development thank
you sir had to get in North Korea yeah
yeah of course of course well this is
one a very important issue
and as you know unfortunately since 2000
0009 the iaea inspectors were banned
from from dprk and we have been as
absent that doesn't mean that we do not
have a pretty good idea of what is going
there I have been trying for those
following this issue closely I've been
trying to have more
in-depth reports on the situation there
on the on what I've called a spawning
nuclear program in the past it used to
be young Beyond and and some well-known
facilities now nowadays has grown into
something much bigger much wider much
more more more complex
as iea we we will take uh eventually
verification mandate from member states
and so there is an assumption that there
should be a political agreement that
doesn't mean that there cannot be
perhaps technical ways to engage at some
point
nuclear safety nuclear security there
are issues that we are exploring
I I am a firm believer on establishing
contacts I had good conversations with
President John in Seoul in this respect
and of course it is the the margin that
we have there is quite limited but I
don't think it is totally excluded that
we can start doing some some work there
in a not so long
director General Garcia you have
delivered a message of optimism
despite a very difficult time I think
you have also delivered a call to action
for all of us to work to uphold
International agreements to avoid
complacency and also to not be afraid of
problems but really work to find
Solutions and to feed them into the
policy process so I really want to thank
you in closing for your leadership and
commitment to these issues and also to
really thank you for the time that
you've taken to come here and offering a
really fresh first-hand account of your
role in the agency's role and the
ongoing work so thank you very much and
everybody please join me in thanking
director General grocery thank you very
much